a friend messaged me to say imagine if
you were married to the conservative
party you'd be demanding a divorce
because you've had 13 years of abuse and
neglect during which they gaslit you and
told you that most of the things you
thought were happening were not
happening and then after admitting that
those things were happening they say to
you but stay with me darling because I
believe I can change all your friends
would be saying leave
him I'm afraid that I think most voters
right now what ever sunak says however
good his intention and there are
individual ministers who I think
genuinely do want to change things like
sella bravman most voters are going to
say I would feel like an idiot to vote
for the party which for the last 13
years has done this how can you possibly
justify that to yourself